-Performing "Scared Money"
from his upcoming album,
"Pray For Me," here's YG
featuring Moneybagg Yo.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[Rapping] ♪ Why you bring
that money to the club ♪
♪ If you ain't throwin' it? ♪
♪ How you naked on the 'Gram
but in person ♪
♪ You ain't showin' it? ♪
♪ Why you go against the gang?
You can't beat 'em, join it ♪
♪ Ain't tap in when you got to
Cali, got your... extorted ♪
♪ Oh, brand new coupe,
I floor it ♪
♪ Oh, brand new...
gotta... it ♪
♪ Oh, brand new Glock,
I adore it ♪
♪ Oh, have a...
runnin' like Forrest ♪
♪ V.I.P, I'm very important ♪
♪ In the hood,
I ain't never no tourist ♪
♪ Got the drop on the opp,
we Dora explore it ♪
♪ Hey, YG from the streets,
YG went legit ♪
♪ Hey, YG lit, YG start
a business with yo... ♪
♪ Hey, fifty... flew to Cabo,
YG a trip ♪
♪ Hey, YG think he Kanye West,
he got his own kicks ♪
♪ Woah, fresh out a pandemic
but I ain't rusty ♪
♪ Woah, have a baby by me...
come be lucky ♪
♪ Woah... I'ma throw it all, all
the strippers love me ♪
♪ Woah, walk in best dressed
but I ain't no Kid Cudi ♪
-Girl, did he just say what
I think he just said?
-♪ Yeah, turn up ♪
-Sis, yes.
-♪ Talkin' like you lit,
your... better not be ugly ♪
♪ Pull up with a ten,
her waist slim, and chubby ♪
♪ Half a milly on my neck,
who gon' take it from me? ♪
♪ Uh-oh, we ballin' on you...
dummies ♪
♪ Hey, scared money
don't make no money ♪
♪ Whoa, scared money
-Whoa! Uh-oh!
-♪ We ballin' on you dummies ♪
-[Rapping] ♪ Ball too hard on...
like Zion ♪
♪ When he bust out the shoe ♪
♪ See that lil' switch
on the Glock ♪
♪ You can't shoot back
when we start shootin' ♪
♪ Thuggin' on the block with YG,
set trippin', my pockets blue ♪
♪ VVVs cost some cheese,
reach for these, I blam on you ♪
♪ Scared money
don't make no money ♪
♪ I got shows comin' in,
but the trap still bunkin' ♪
♪ Wrapped the Lamb' truck white,
but the inside's pumpkin ♪
♪ Grip her neck when we be... ♪
♪ And she like when
I talk country ♪
-♪ Whoa♪
-♪ Big speaker, yeah ♪
♪ Big talker ♪
♪ Have your cash together, cost
a Mike V for a truffle boat ♪
♪ Dollars, followers,
and ratchet... ♪
♪ I got a lot of those ♪
♪ Gettin' me some... waitin' on
my food to cook at Pappadeaux ♪
♪ Big Bagg ♪
-♪Talkin' like you lit ♪
♪ Your... better not be ugly ♪
♪ Pull up with a ten,
her waist slim... chubby ♪
♪ Half a milly on my neck,
who gon' take it from me? ♪
-Uh-oh!
-♪ We ballin' on you dummies ♪
-♪ Bagg, what we tell 'em? ♪
-♪ Scared money don't make
no money ♪
♪ Scared money
don't make no money ♪
-Whoa, uh-oh!
-Uh-oh!
♪ We ballin on you... dummies ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]